Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to PREY
Now on the last episode we were trying to figure out what Neuro-mod to be using
and you guys said that hacking is a very useful one
but you said that hacking doesn't get useful until you get about to hacking III (Three)
Also useful is repair, also useful is necropsy
Because the benefit of necropsy is that I get more organs from the typhon
which means that I'm going to be able to use those
to make more exotic materials which is used in
the fabrication of neuromods!
So I don't know...if that's like a direct correlation but -
If it's like in a-- If it's like
You know, in any economy, you wanna go for the route
that gives you more of the thing, that allows you to upgrade more.
So for now... I need physician to be able to get to that point.
And I'm pretty sure I'm on'a need physician!
Because I seem to be taking a lot of damage!
I'm not saying I'm bad at this game!
I'm saying I'm just new to this game...
Oh god, NO!
AH! *silent terror*
Ahhh...!
WHAT?
*high pitched* I thought it was just gonna be like a suction cup!
You didn't tell me needles were gonna jab into my BRAIN!
Okay...!
*weak laugh*
Oh hi, you're still open- You're very shocked about all of this.
He's like: " *exaggerated gasp* I can't belive they killed me with that bullshit!"
Ok. So, uhm-
Anyway...
I think we uh-
Huh-- I think we found everything we need to find in this area,
we need to get to the Lobby area. The Skill Recording Room??
I don't know what that's all about, but I think we've been everywhere around here...
Except for maybe in here...? Have we been in here???
Oh no... oH NO, that was hacking level one!
AGHH NOOO!
I could've gotten in there! Ah, I take it back!
Ah, load, load, load it back!
I take it back!
I'm not above this! *laughs* I am not above this!
I am not above this, I am a man who wants to
stab himself in the eye again!
To be able to get hacking one
because you guys told me hacking wasn't gonna be able to be- AHHH!
Frick, I should have followed my intuition-
Oh god, not this again!
aaaaaAAAAAGH!
Ohhhay... [Alright...]
Hahahahoh, jeez!
It's like I really am Morgan Yu, I'm just doing this over and over again...
unless I'm not. -January speaking in the BG-
Oh, thank you, January
Just a second January,
There was a reason I did that again
Wham~! Bam~!
Thank... you... ma'am
Hello dude...oh
Awww, but now I need-
ah, I wouldn't have gotten Necropsy anyway
so that's fine
but I didn't get that- these organs here
so I gotta make sure I get all these
oh wow that guy had a whole bunch of stuff
9 mm bullets!
Am I going to be getting a gun any time soon?
Ha-boink~!
Wee-- Ohh...
*reading instructions*
oh... OH-- Ow!
Ow--
I don't know how to do this!
uuuaAAAGH!
Ok I think I got it
'C'! -Victory Tone-
I HACKED!
LOOK AT MY HACKING FINGERS!
Hacker voice-- I'm in~!
What the hell is that?
Found an up an--
wh-- You can use these to upgrade weapons...?
*more instructions*
Okay...!
select the weapon I want to upgrade
well I could upgrade my GLOO gun
to be able to spew more GLOO everywhere
that's something I've always wanted to do!
I think
unless I can upgrade this thing
no
upgrade ok
I guess I can only upgrade this
OOOH!
reduce the GLOO ammunition required to incapacitate
handling, range, reload
I'll do this one, I'll upgrade that
I've always wanted to be more efficient about my GLOO
I mean, heh
Eh, I gotta shut up about that
Anyway- so I got that now
so that's good I guess
but I don't have a password for this- AW
if I had Hacking II
Security Stations track all the employees aboard Talos I
What? ...Oh... *more instructions*
Wow, that lady on the right does NOT look ok
I'm just saying
somethings off about that
Alrighty then... that's good
huh
Well alright then!
uh OOO!
*reads memo*
Oh ok... why?
Uh but why though?
Ok whatever, it doesn't matter
Let's carry on, we've wasted enough time
I know I've been exploring the environment
a whole hell of a lot in this game
but that's just cuz', like, I'm honestly so curio-
Oh, okay, favorite wheel
*reading*
Ok, so mouse 1 to favorite wheel
AH!
Oh I can use a med kit right from there!
Oh that's good!
and I got the bonus- No I don't have the bonus for med kit anymore
because I don't have the - for NECROPSY!
It's like a trade-off no matter what you do
but I'm going to go for Necropsy next
Uh, if- this'll be useful in case I need to break into any
keypads that I come across, so I will be able to use that
So long as I can hack it ok
which is not always generally guaranteed here
don't know why... January's complimenting me on my skills
OOOOH
Eh hey *nervous laugh*
Hey buddy!
HI!
AAAAAH... how's it going friend?
AHHH it's my buddy!
Alrighty then
No I am not
Why- why is there a real view
is it all a fake world?
Oh, I'm in space
OH I'M IN SPACE!
OH!
YES!
I'M IN SPACE!
I LIKE SPACE!
I like space a lot
I like space a lot- oh hi
Ok
I took this tulip
CAUSE I'M IN SPACE!
Oh geez, tape drive - carry with leverage 3
How that does that give me more le-
How does that make leverage allow me to carry that?
I'm pretty sure I can't leverage my way to hauling giant boxes
Ah, whatever
I'm not gonna complain- Hello
OOOOH that gives me health
Fancy that, but I've had enough to drink I guess
*singing gibberish* OOOHHH it's beauti- *noises*
OOHHH!
Well, goodbye!!!
*January speaking*
I do! Who are you?
Oh, that's - No, that's not what I wanted
Oh *silent burp* Excuse me, that's beautiful!
Oh, that's beautiful - Ok
*reading* Talas I (one) is open for you to explore  from the lobby, you can  reach oth-
AHHHH right, never mind then!
Access the video file, ok!
I'm gonna - DOWAH!
I saw that
Wait, I saw that!
BOOP
Ok, never mind
I thought I saw...
I- I almost forgot for a second
where I was
and why I was here
I saw that
HIYAH! HIYAH! HIYAH! Ok
I thought I saw something!
I might be a little paranoid here but I think it's for good reason!
You can't trust anything!
Or anyone!
EVER
Alright, I'll take the used cigar, that's good for my health
GLORP GLORP ok
Alrighty- Oh hello
Shotgun shells? Am I gonna get a shotgun anytime soon?
Can I get in here? I've got hacking skills! Ooh...
Wait, there's- No, stop that!
There's a safe in there, ok
So either way, I need to get to my place
Of some sort
So that I can get something
I don't remember what
*Station announcement*
Ok, why though?
But- but why?
Everyone seems to already be dead
AYYY WHY! WHY!
Hey, hi, OK!
NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO NO
How about you get bap! YOU GET BAP!
WOAH!!! YOU GET BAP BAP BAP BAP BAP BAP BAP
GET GLUED!
I've got so much glue! It's so much more efficient!
You don't even know the same glue anymore
Oh yeah, you think- I've evolved!
AH BAP! BAP!
Okay, man I wish I had necropsy
I'd be able to take these tumors here
I don't know what good they would do-AAAHH
I HAD MY KARATE CHOP RAISED IF YOU WANNA MESS WITH ME!
Oh god, what happened?
Holy shit you're beautiful, BAM
I'm gonna break you though, but you're beautiful
God I need necropsy, I'm missing out on so much shit
Jesus
*reading*
Good...
I think
That's good right? I hope
Alrighty then, hello, hi
Hiddy hiddy hiddy ho
Oh... psychotronics staff only
Oh I don't know what that is
Hello can I get in here?
Can I bash this open?
Alright nevermind then
You all carry on, you have a lovely day
You have a lo- oh good blood
Great...good
Can I have these...? OH, lovely!
I'll just be flower picking for the rest of this duration
That looks like...
That looks flammable, that looks flammable
looks extremely flammable
Hello?
Anybody want some GLOO in here?
I've got an excess of glue, it's VERY efficient
You'd be amazed at my glue!
Everyone would be amazed at my glue...hello?
Alright, fine then
Okay
I'll take that, agave plant clippings
Gonna make some...some sweet, sweet agave nectar
Alright...uh okay
Getting a lot of med kits which make me think something bad is gonna happen
*reading*
Well that's good! Good to know people are still squatting in the future
Umm...
AY fucking god dammit
Jesus Christ
You guys still spook me
Nooo, no!
Where'd your friend go, huh?
Gimme your tumors!
I want them real bad
Okay so is your guy...is he blended in?
He's blended in isn't he?
*sudden loud music* HEY!
Where was he?
Alright I'm gonna forget about him
I'll come back and get him later- *loud sound* WHY
Hello?
Okay, I'm gonna pretend like that's nothing apparently
Get these goodies
Oh good! A lemon peel, let me just stuff that in my pants
*weird sound* ...why?
Turrets...are you friendly?
Thank you I appreciate that!
I'd like to think that I'm not a-
AY what the fuck!
Jesus Christmas
Oh the turret got him
Hey turret can you take care of that guy too?
Turret...turret?
Turret...thank you turret!
That turret's useful
I don't need to waste any of my gloo
I value my very, very efficient gloo
Hello
Hi, okay yeah I'll take-
Why did you have bio hazard waste on you?
Why?
eugh, sky king pomegranite
*weird beep* OH, hi
Hello
Okay...hello
Key card required...no oxygen detected beyond this point, proceed at your own risk
You know what?
For my- for the sake of mine own risk I don't think I'm gonna go over there
Oh god
Eugh what happened to you?
What happened?
Eugh hu hu
Alrighty then
Carrying on
Oh yeah I need to get to uh, my office
I almost forgot about my freaking office
Geez...alrighty then
Habooski, habooski, hello
No! I need that!
Maybe...I don't know
I don't know man, okay...
So it's...up there
Okay, so I gotta get up there
Maybe...
AYYY! What the fuck?!!!
The turret! Help me!
Help me turret!!!
Alien threat?
Alien- wait, ALIEN threat?!
Whoa...
Well these turrets are awesome
It just said ALIEN threat though
So...
When it says alien threat is it talking, like...
FOR REAL aliens here?
Because I was under the impression that these things were things that
this corporation, whatever it is
Transtar, I think it was
That this corporation had made
Not that it was...
Utilizing aliens
So my understanding right now as it stands- what I know thus far
Is that I may not be human
But... I may be alien
Or something along those lines, I'm not 100% sure
Can I hack that?
Please tell me I can hack that
No, apparently not, ok.
But...
That doesn't make the most sense I've ever heard
That just  makes a little bit- Ooh
Hi
Ooh, is that a neuromod?
Yeeesss
GIVE me YOU! Thank you!
Thank you for that!
I think, anyway. Thank you!
I'll take THAT as well, thank you!
*high pitched* Hurray! Goody!
Ok
So I need to go up
I've wasted enough time, god, I just- *noises*
Hi
Oooohhhh...
OOOHHHH
HIYAH! Ok, alright I just wanted to check, I was pretty sure that was going to be the real one!
But that means...
There's a trash can up there
Ahh...
Oh ho ho!
Get ready *laughs* for a big load of my gloo
BLEH!
bleh *station announcement*
What?
AHH! Goddammit I glooed you!
I glooed you!!!
I glooed you up!
Geezums...
You sack of shit
You sa- oh, hi
*Groaning*
*more groaning*
*smol groan*
Oh, the trauma center
Wait, I needed to go into the trauma center
For SOME reason
I can't- Oh, bul- bubla- *blubbering*
Blamblebow!
Blammy! Blammy!  Blamy! Below me?
Whoa...
Hello
I'm up here now!
Oh my god
That's so cool!
Oh, I hope I get to go out there
Oh, I hope I get to go out there!
OH I hope I get to go out there!
I mean, it'd be very Dead Space if it did that
But in a way...
This game does kind of give off a bit of Dead Space vibes
Maybe like a mixture of Dead Space and Bioshock is actually a good way to describe this game right-
THAT'S A GUN!
Can I has that?
Wait, there's TWO guns
Is one of those a Mimic?
*high pitched to low* I'm thinking maybe one of those is a Mimic
Alrighty then
Just a bunch of Dittos from Pokemon
Oh, hi
Ok, there's a turret over there, that's gonna be useful
This is a nice office, ooh, what's this?
OH, FOR THE TRAUMA CENTER!
Oh, good! I can go down there and I can go for Dr. blehblehblehblabla
Ok, emails
*Reading*
For where?
What are you talking about?
7703, where is that... code to?
Ok, thank you- oh, no, hang on, wait
Uhhh...
*Reading*
Let's see...
Ok, thank you
*Reading*
Get scanned for what?
What are they scanning for? Some sort of brain mapping here?
Is there like some sort of SOMA application here?
I don't know what it's all for
Well that's super weird, and I got a code but I don't know what it's to
Maybe some volunteer headquart- woah
This office looks a little more... dilapidated than the last one
*Reading*
Ok, so...
Our brains are a little bit of a quantum computer, is that what we're talking about here?
*Reading*
From Morgan Yu, supposedly that's me
Oh wait, hang on
*Reading*
So who is this?
This is Sylvan Bellamy, OH!
That's Bellamy! That's Dr. Bellamy! That's the guy that is supposedly dead because he's been attacked
By something
*Reading/mumbling*
Ah, I've already read that one about the consciousness thing
Oh, man, ok. Moving on, moving on, moving on! Hello
Movin' on, movin' on, movin' on!
What have we got here?
Oh, hello. Is this your password?
"OMG!hotboss"
You- you talkin' about me? Oh...
You talkin' about Jason Chang?
This is my office, right? *noises* HI?
Thank you!
*January speaking*
Thank you, how do YOU know that?
How do you KNOW that?
Alright, whatever
*Reading*
Wha- I just-
Wa- I was just about to find that out
Wait, what?
*dialogue*
Woah *dialogue*
Where'd that come from? *dialogue*
*dialogue*
I don't--
I don't know where I got that
I don't think I got it from right here.
ATTITUDE Adjustment?!
I don't need an attitude adjustment!
Especially not with bul-lets!
Okay... 0451
Wow, that would take a Hacking of FOUR.
I guess I got good security on my own office here.
MY office.
Yeah!
I sure-- I BELIEVE that. Oh YEAH.
I'm sure it has.
Okay
Whatever you s--
Oh, helo--ooh!
Hello!~
Oohh, hello, hello.~
Hello!
Helloo!
Hello.~
Hi
Ooh, hello.
Ooh, I don't know what I got, but I got something good.
Ohh its a Morgan Yu's suite
I don't know where that is but I got that
Ooooh a fabricator?
OOOOOH I can make a wrench
I DONT HAVE ENOUGH INGREDIENTS
fabricators can be used to create weapons
*deep breath*
*reading*
AH!
those are the materials that i just picked some up and i've gooot
and my inventory is kinda full
suit modification skill increases inventory size
ok i'll get to that but i've got
synthetic material, organic material and mineral material.
So that's good
oh, biohazard. refrigerate or recycle imediately
okay.. Nah, i'll just carry it on me. I'd rather risk disease and keep this really cool biowaste
so if i can.. place items in
Ooo
Ah, so this is how-
Oh, it gives materials...Okay
So, that's why I have this stuff...
So what's junk and what's not junk? Is it the grey stuff?
Okay, I'm gonna trust this
I don't if this is 100%-
I mean, I'm assuming it's, if-if
If a lemon peel is grey
i'm assuming that means it's junk. right?
Typhon organ contains exotic material which is used to faBRICATE NEUROMODS
That's what I need necropsy for!
So do I...?
Do I recycle that? I think I recycle that
And then...
Wait, there was an auto-sort
Okay, that is...helpful, I guess
Recycle...yeah!
Yeah- WOAH
The future is NOW!!
Oh HELL yeah, oh HEEELLLLL yeah
Okay so I can take these and I can fabricate stuff right?
Can I make more neuromods?
Ugh, I don't have the recipe for it
God dammit- ooo what is this?
Operator Designator...?
-dispenser? Designator, dispenser. I am not doing words correctly right now
Okay anyway- woah
Baseball glove
Seach for- OOHHHH
The motherLOAD
Why yes please
Hello
*reading*
Okay...well I know my-
my, uh, my password
I could hack it- nah I know my password
It's fine I know it!
Hello, ah!
*reading*
I don't know what that means
Oh...
Okay, so I had a relationship of some sort...?
*reading*
Okay, cool. Cool, cool, cool
Hello, AHH!
The whole family is here!
Everyone is looking awfully grim
And also uh...
That's a rather ominous symbol of my jacket quote unquote
Wait I can make gloo amo!!
I can make more gloo! My gloo!
Never mind, you know what I'm not even gonna go there
I'm gonna cut it with the gloo jokes, but hopefully...
if I do this right...
I can make more gloo!
I can make gloo!
Hell yeah!
Oh shit, dude!
Is there any reason I shouldn't be making as much gloo as I possibly can?
Cause it seems like there's a good bit of salvageable here
So that's good, okay
So...what is this?
*reading*
Huh, okay then
So...*reading* Watch me Morgan
*reading*
AM I??
Any mimics in here??
Play, okay
Oh...hello
Ooohhh, hi!
Hello, hello?
Am I supposed to step in there-WHAM
WOAH
I didn't mean to do that!
I di- I do- I did not mean to do that!
Oh, fucking god dammit, I didn't mean to do that!
OH, 5150
Wait...
Fucking god dammit I didn't mean to do this!!
Okay hang on
Wait...woAH
Ooohhh god why did I break that?
But there's something back here
What is that?
Where am I?
Okay, Alex
Okay
Alllright, okay Alex, if that is your real name
Okay, but that room-
That room was right outside,
of the-the-the-the place where I woke up from, where they were containing everything
Okay...
Alright Calvino?
Okay but 5150 that is the key code to the safe in the original area where I just was
Now it'd be a long trek to go back there, I may go back there at some point, but now I know that
Woah, hey woahwoahwoahwoahbbbrah
Shoot 'em! Shoot 'em shoot 'em shoot 'em
Okay good!
-as quick and painless as possible? What are you talking about? Quick and painless?
Are you trying to execute people? What are you talking about?
But either way, if I go back there eventually-which I will at some point in this game
I will open that safe, but probably not in this episooooode...
*reading* I know how to fight!
I know how to shoot my gloo at the enemy
You tell me you don't know think I know how do that?
Oh!
Hi, I'm gonna go back to the turret
Yaboodaboo
Okay buddy you wanna fight me over here-
OOOHHH mistake! Mistake baby
What a mistake you made!
Okay, hi!
Hi! How's it going over there?
There's a gun and I want it!
Bloop! BLoop!
Get glued! Bloop
Oh, no! You've been...GLUED
BLAPP...okay
Got that one...can I have that?
AH! I knew it! I called that!
Blap Blap
Okay I called that
Totally called that
Sorry-Ehh why'd you twitch
Hey! I can make bullets!
*Weird Mark noise*
Alright okay
Alright okay!
Good ol' fashioned 9mm silence pistol
Hehehe
So what good is this gonna do me in the face of the Typhon
Are the Typhon particularly susceptible to bullets?
I'm gonna say that's a yes.
I'm not 100% sure about anything though
Alright
Anymore Neuro-mods for me to get? Nope.
Okay Alright then
Oh good, Paper and bullshit.
So glad I'm gathering up-
Is this where I'm supposed to go?
Looks like that might be a yes!
Alrighty then
I might need to make a run to the-the salvager
Yeah, I'm getting pretty full-up on here
So I'm probably gonna make a run to the salvager and also...
How did a corpse get all the way over here?
What is this? Aw I don't have repair!
I know I've got neuromods, but I'm trying to go for necropsy here
Oh!
BOOM baby!
That wasn't as...glorious as I thought it was going to be
So before I go there, I'm just gonna run back real quick
I'm gonna run back real quick and I'm gonna salvage what I got
And then I'm gonna try to craft more bullets because that's gonna be good for me
HAAABOOSKY
Thank you for that
And also if I can ever find a key card to the thing behind-
*weird noises*
hi...
OHH AH fucking hi
Hi
Okay
You wanna get glued buddy-boo? You wanna get glued?!
There's not a turret nearby is there?
Alright buddy...alright buddy
Alright, okay
So how you doing?
How you doing?
Where you at? OH Jesus!
No need to be so angry about everything!
Some things aren't worth getting angry about
Oh yeah, oh yeah you keeping walking over there
You big dumb doof! You DOOF
Get ready...I mean I'm gonna gloo him then I'm gonna shoot-
Yuri? Wait, Yuri?!
Wait Yuri? Why's his name Yuri?
It was surprisingly effective!
But why...why was it's name Yuri?
If it's name was Yuri-Yuri Kimura
It doesn't say phantom, it doesn't say mimic!
That say Yuri Kimura!
It's like, I'm not going out of my mind here, that's Yuri Kimura
And there's a reason-THIS IS YURI KIMURA
Neuromod install technician
The turret said something about aliens
These neuromods...
must be something derived from these typhon
Which aren't made by this company, these must be actual legit...entities
That we're trying to reverse engineer
Ooohh shit!
Oh hell yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh frick dude!
Here comes another eye jab- I've got EIGHT? Holy shit
Okay I can get necropsy
Okay yeah I can do this
Oh good I don't need to stab myself in the eye again that's good!
But then I can do...necropsy
Which means I'm going to eventually get more neuromods
Hell yeah!
And then I can get...
I can get leverage, I can get repair
I could get conditioning
I could get combat focus, stealth
ooo that'd be nice
I'm gonna to for the level 1 things
Just because...they're cheap,
and they open up the doors for a lot. Especially this repair one and I've already seen things that need to be repaired
So that's good
I don't think I necessarily need these things because I seem to be doing a lot better about damage
So that's probably good
Let's see...*reading*
So someone was trying to export something here
But I'm thinking because Yuri Kimura, that just suggests that she was doing some shady stuff-she or he- I have no idea
was doing some shady stuff
And that means something
...right? That means something. Anyway...
*reading* "it's just a little pick-prick near the eye, right?"
Yeah, a liiiiiittle pin-prick
*back to reading*
Okay
So that's, that's a side effect I think we already knew about, but that's still weird-
HAEY FUCKING GOD DAMMIT
Fuck you dude!
Fuck you!
ugh
*sigh* Thank you for that but as least I got necropsy and I can do that
I already knew about that one
Huh boy
Oh I fucking turned- what is this?! OH!
OH! *reading*
Ooohh I've got a nerf crossbow!
Good, I guess?
*high pitched voice* I think, I'm not so sure about that one. I don't know why I have that but okay
*normal voice* But okay, there was a benefit to coming over here because I got a whole bunch of neuromods
Which is good
Because now at least I can go what I need to go
That's the space elevator, that's the baseball glove...
Oh yeah! I totally forgot I was going- I was going to get recycling! I was about to recycle-Ohh
I know a secret path when I see one!
And this is definitely a secret path!
Hello, OOHH
Ah! FUCKING GODDAMMIT STOP IT WITH THAT SHIT!
You fucking asshole!
You fucking- I was doing great, not taking-oohhh shit
I'll come get you later, I didn't realize I could break the floor like that
Fuck man these guys are dicking with me
Ooooo
That's nice! Habooski!
My arms have gotten stronger!
I guess I got a lot of med kits, holy shit
These guys are dicking with me
Can I hack this? Ooo I can!
Alright let's see if I can hack something in here
Alright got it
Play a little game here
Hup... and 'c"
YAAY!! I did it, okay I don't know what that did but I did it
Oh, hi-oh
"what do you see it the glass?" what are you talking about?
What are you talking about?
Okay, I'm running out of bullets
I've got enough glue and I've got full- HEY
There's a thing-there's a thing right next to him
That do any damage?
Aaahhhh, AAHH WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT-OOHHH
Suit integrity?! Is this really the time?
HO
I don't have enough bullets, there was another one in there
It doesn't seem to have noticed that I'm just killing his dude
I've got enough for one shot on like...that cannon there
Uh-oh. aaaAAHH NOO! Oh god!
Oh I should've reloaded
Alright I'm gonna bash you, gonna bash you, gonna bash you-
Woah where'd you go, where'd you go, where'd you go??
Hello woah hey, hey, hey no need for that
No need for that, no need for that
Woah you had a lot of stuff on you!
Holy shit, okay
Oh my god, you had even more!
They both had stuff on them!
OH! I got a whole bunch of shit!
I got- I got THREE upgrade kits?!
Oh shit okay
So I'm gonna upgrade this, I guess
Upgrade that bad boy to more...*mumbling* firepower, magazine, accuracy...
Firepower first...
Uhhh, then I'm gonna upgrade the gloo gun because it's really useful
toooo reload speed maybe?
Reload, and then...
I could always use more handling
The range is fine
I would like be able to move faster while I use it though
Okay, that's good!
I need-I need to dump my salvage
I keep forgetting! I'm supposed to go dump my salvage then I got-
I kept getting distracted
Security office, okay I got that
That's good
I think the security office is downstairs by the shuttle bay if I remember correctly
Authorized personnel, clearance required, okay key card only
No hacking on that one
Where am I?
Ah... *reading*
Okay, alright
Jesus
Okay well that was go- woah
The frick happen there?
Sorry I blinked and though I was in a different dimension or something
So where's--OOooohhhh
Ooohhh...Okay
Okay alright I'm down with that!
Well- oh my health is low, geez
Alright there we go, I'm all full up
I need to eat my food now- eugh...
I saw that
I saw that!
I saw that...
OOOHHHH
OOHHH GET REKT BITCH
GET REKT
get rekt
OOHHH get re-e-e-ekt
OOHH Nelly!
And I'm gonna guess you are one too, but I don't have enough...
to get you
Alright I saw how this is going
I don't know that doesn't seem to work
I have a funny feelings there's another one in here
Ooo recyclable! OH handy!
Okay...grey...grey, grey, grey *mumbling* grey, grey, grey
There's gotta be a way to do that easier
I've got a lot of food here but I'm gonna eat it next time I get hurt which I'm sure I'm going to be
*mumbling* 'F' to transfer junk, okay
Wait is that the fast way to do that?
Huh, whatever
Alright, yes please, thank you
I like that, very convenient for me to have that there
*reading*
Well thanks Alex! Big bro, you're suck an inspiration for every- hEY
Oh, hey I was wrong
Kay woah, can you fucking stop?
Can you stop being such a douche for one goddamn second of your goddamn life
I'm gonna drink this and eat this and that's gonna be the end of that!
You guys are gonna shut up, you guys are gonna let me live,
so I can get back to my goddamn office which is what I meant to do the whole time here!
Our psychos- *loud sound* Why?
Where- What did I just do?
I need to stop hopping up on things
Noooo
No no no blap and blap
Okay, you're dead now
I love that necropsy
Hopefully that's gonna pay off in the long run because right now it doesn't seem like I'm going to be able to get anything
Except a lot of food here
But for now...
*reading*
Ah, good!
Great! So I'm guessing...
This place called Pytheas...
Is where I'm going to be going next
I'm probably going to go down to Pytheas...
Probably where they found the typhon! I'm gonna call that right now
In that mining station on Pytheas, is where they FOUND the-the typhon,
and THAT'S where all this came from, and THAT'S where it is and THAT'S why it's terrifying
Cause it's all in your mind
That's what it is isn't it?
How close am I guys? How close am I?
Just on the little bit that I got here...
I'm a mimic
I'm a mimic, I'm calling that right now
I'm a mimic beCAUSE of neuromods
and the constant installation
because the neuromods are BASED on the typhons
which are aliens, which is why Yuri was a typhon
and she got infected by it and turned into one of them
because they're aliens and it's bad tech!
How close am I? How nailed on the head do I got that bad boy?
I feel 100% confident about that one
I feel 100% confident that I got it all on lock
Oh god, I need to go in the trauma center
But frick there's so many things to explore I keep getting forgetting what I need to do
Okay, uhh...
Oooh, if I just hold down 'F' that's gonna be- that's way easier
But I've got all this food that I...
I either need to need or do something with it, I guess I could recycle it
...I guess?
Would it be a waste?
Would it be a waste to recycle all this?
I did just get a lot of it, I don't need all that much of it I guess
I mean I'm doing okay, I'm not dying horribly which is nice
*high pitched voice* Ah, you know what, why not?
I'm doing all right
I can live on the edge, I've got 1 neuromod here I didn't even know I had
So, that's good
*high pitched* Ah, you know what-*unintelligible*
Bling blang blang blong
Okay, so I'm out of here. God,
I got SO sidetracked there, but that's just like...
that's what I actually really like about this game is like it's...
it's got a lot of- Can I drop down here safely?
Ah! Okay I'm fine
I can uh...I can just explore for a while and I can just-
Okay yeah, is it because our brains are being scrambled?
This is like, very Dead Space-y. I'm not gonna lie about this, but this is very Dead Space-y
And I got the security office key which means...
I might be able to get something here
Hello, ah!
This all looks very bad!
Okay then
So...it seems like these are all in error and not usable
That is broken as shit, that all broken
There's nothing here good, there's emails
*reading*
Huh...weird
Okay, then. Oh, another weapon upgrade, I'm getting lots of those, that's good
Kay, woah *gasp*
OOHHH HELL YEAH BABY! HELL YEAH
HELL YEAH! Okay got that
*reading*
So I gotta be point-blank on these bad boys
...Okay...
That's nice
Oh, I can't hack that...oh okay
*reading*
That's weird
That's super weird
*reading*
Like mimics?
What is white noise?
*reading*
What?
Okay...
*reading*
Okay, thank you, I don't know what the holding room is
Is this the holding room?!
Is this the holding room?
This is the holding room...Uhm
Uh...okay
Alright...who's in here again?
Not that, could've hacked it but...1129 I guess
Oh!
Hey, FUCKING GODDAMMIT you FUCKING ASSHOLE
fuck these assholes
Oh my god
Wait so that's Demetri Boswer
What
Ooohh the mimic was the chair he was on
Oh
*reading*
Yuri Kimura
That's the one that was in her office
Man what is going on here, what is happening?!
I was just-
I literally was just trying to go back and salvage some stuff
before I continued on to the main quest!
I got so sidetracked, but it's FASCINATING!
It's FASCINATING! Download area map?
It's FASCINATING!
There's just so much here!
I haven't been able to go anywhere and I don't care it's awesome!
And what is going on in psychotronics?!
What is happening over there?!
Look, I have no idea and I love it!
I love it so much, this is SO COOL!
But now I'm finally gonna go back up to my office
so I can salvage some stuff
And I still need to go into there!
Let me go in here first!
Geez, one last stop before I go where I need to go
because supposedly...ugh
This is where Bellamy is or Bellaimy or whatever it is
Hello
I'll take that, yes. How full is my inventory right now?
Not full, that's right I forgot that I actually found...
Oh wait Sylvain Bellamy: tracking bracelet?
Okay
So, I don't have his tracking bracelet
So that means I can't track him through the system, right?
Download area map, okay
So...
Okay so that helped with the trauma center I think
Okay but...that's fine
So what I need to do, I need to find...
Dr. Bellamy
Uh...
*reading*
Man these words...
Is that the person they were calling something about white noise?
Is that what that was about?
*reading*
So he's not here, that's why his collar was here...
Bellamy's not here
He's in psychotronics
Hello, thank you for that
So...
How do I get to psychotronics?
Uh...uh...hi...oh, hello
Was that guy on fire?
Why is that guy on fire?
Garfield what?
*softly* What the fuck?
What the fuck is going on here?
Did they hear that?
So I'm gonna try to be sneaky about this because that one's on fire...
So I'm assuming it's bad
Yeah you heard that didn't you?
Oh yeah you heard that
Ooohhh yeah you heard that
You heard that, oh yeah
Come on, come on a little close
Let me get you a shot gun right to the face huh?
Want some of that?
Oh, you both coming aren't you?
Oh, you both are coming
I don't if that's good that both of you are coming
Oh! Oh my god, BAM
Bam bitch! Oh, you wanna get swonked
Swink swonk-Ohwaa-a-a-hey
Hey none of that, none of that! I need to reload my gloo
Okay, alright you wanna dance?
Wanna dance buddy-ooOHH hey!
Put the fire out!
Put the fire out, oh boy!
Is he out? Why is not-
Jesus Christmas-AH it's a harmless crossbow!
OH MY GOD
AAAHHHH!
AAH!
Okay I need- AHH GODDAMM IT!
Holy shit dude!
That guy is tough!
That's guy's tough!
I was not prepared for that!
I was NOT prepared for that
Okay so what I need to do is I need to lead him to the explosive things
Because I think THAT....
Where am I? Have I read these yet?
Yeeaah, okay there we go. And then the  utilities, I need to get the area map again
God dammit I need to save more, there is a quick save to this one,
but now...I have all this stuff and I got the materials I need right there
I got that
Okay...so I need to lead them...
to...those-
that's not what I meant to do
Did I just set off the explosives?
I think I did
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god
Okay, there's someone here. I can take care of the little guy
YOU I can take care of
Get Blapped! NOO! Blapp 'em!
Oh, I- EUGH Fucking woah
That fire guy is ridiculous!
That guy is ridiculous!
How is anyone supposed to handle that?!
Geezums, okay so there's more explosive canisters over here
I just gotta throw them at them
Cause I got my super throw ability now
If I can throw it at them...
Let me just drop this for a second, I'm going to get my pistol out
If I throw it...
Go after it, woah!
I guess if I just throw those it does it
Okay so the gloo doesn't seem to do anything to them
but if I just THROW these at them, he's already on fire, that's why it works
That makes sense
Okay, where you going buddy, where you going?
Oh yeah, you want some of THIS?
BOOM! Did that hurt you?
Okay alright, I'm going to get this guy
Not with the crossbow! I need to take that off my favorites because that is not helpful
BAM! Bam? Holy shit
Holy shit! Where'd you-where'd he go?
Hello! Where are you? Come here, come here, come here
I want you-WHAM! BAM!
Woa... what the fuck
Okay I got him though
Man, it gave me a weapon mod
Man, those guys give great shit!
Those guys give great shit!
Hello...hi!
Hello?
Mind controlled-? Trevor J. Young (mind-controlled)
What does that mean?
Hello?
Okay I can't hack that, I don't have a code, okay
I'm gonna...I'll come back to you when I...
when I figure out why you're in there
I have a bad feeling about you being in there but...alright
So why is he mind controlled?
So there is something about this and I'm willing to bet it has something to do with psychotronics
Like, all the psychotronics
And again, I come in here
Just expecting to go on to the salvage place and then I go the trauma center and everything goes to shit!
Ugh, free neuromod though, I like that
I like that, I like that a lot
Oh hello, hi
Request operator...? *robot voice* requesting new operator
Sorry, hi
Oh!
Man, 3D printing got awesome!
Thank you!
Well that's awesome!
Free healing
Well hot damn!
That's handy! That handy-dandy!
*reading*
Okay...weird
OH! White noise!
*reading*
What? Wait, they're brain can't be mapped?
So you are talking about brain scans like Soma?
Are you?
Are you??
Oh shit, I don't have a password I can't hack that
Uhh...med kit fabricator oooo
Oops? Who said oops?
Oh
Okay...alright then
Eugh hi
Okay, hello
Oh good
Excuse me, I'm just gonna take some bio-hazard away from here
Is that your bio hazard? Oh good, more bio hazard!
Oh good
Is this where they map the brain?
Oh, that's so weird!
So there is something to that
That's gotta be right?
No, I'm not shut up!
Shut up you asshole!
Oh, hi. Don't mind me taking your bananas...
"You're planning on a vacation..." Oh, no that's the same test I just took
Jesus
Good cop/bad cop, Good cop/good cop?
*reading*
Okay...I don't know what that's for, I don't think anyone here is being...
This is all just medical stuff
*reading*
"...we couldn't contain it after that"
What?!
*continued reading*
What is that talking about?
*reading*
What the hell?
Something about a psychoscope
I'm assuming that's taking place in psychotronics to do with the typhon
"Session logs"
Waaa, sorry!
I meant to carry that I guess
Sorry!
I'm sorry
I don't know why I was so angry at that white board
That white board just deserved it
Did you see the way it looked at me?
Yeah, I think so
What did I do??
I didn't mean to do that!
Okay, broken cooler fan, note
*reading*
Uhh, okay
Alright I'm gonna put away that because that's just dangerous to have in my hands to be able to shoot at any moment
Sorry! God, I'm a bull in a china shop
Oh, medical operator broken
Well this isn't the one I shot so...
I don't know why I'd need to repair this any way because I've already got one out there
There might be, like, a special reason, maybe that medical operator knows something
Okay...
Alright, you know what?
I'm going to just take a little bit of a breather and take all of this in
I know I meant to get back to...
What?!
Huh, okay I'm going to put the brakes on for now
And end this episode here because I literally just stumbled into a world of everything
I had no idea I was going to dive, but it's AWESOME!
There's so much here!
I didn't mean to do this completion style, I just kind of fell into it!
Man! I'll get back to my main objective over there in just a second but,
I've got a code to that guy's door, so I'm going to find out what, uh
What that's all about in the next episode because something's going on here in psychotronics,
some reason and I don't know why!
But I will find out!
So thank you everybody so much for watching! Let me know what you think down in the comments below
And as always, I will see you in the next video
Ba-bye!